yeah welcome to a new video and the
first video in the series some with a
detailed look at particular opening the
first one will be the Kings gambit so
fighting the Kings gambit with black you
don't get this opening so so often but
of course you need to have some idea
what to do I think them objectively
strongest continuations maybe um go
along the line so I show this briefly
it's not my recommendation but I'll
still show it I guess maybe the
strongest something along these lines
which you can immediately see um is some
rather sharp approach by black weakening
the King also but keeping the pawn these
lines are very interesting to analyze
but I think the problem is that while
you get a Kings gambit in a serious game
every couple of years maybe and I for
instance I never got it in a tournament
game after playing e5 for a couple of
years so it's difficult to memorize all
the sharp stuff so I think it's good to
have one very dependable line again the
King's gambit that you can always play
if you don't have any specific idea what
else to play against it for instance if
you face a particular player where you
know is playing the King's gambit all
the time you might think okay I'll
prepare something special or do
something else but you need some
reliable line that I'm try to um present
here one very reliable answer and this
is some d5 the idea being that white
doesn't have some doesn't have much else
than capturing on d5 now and then
capturing on f4
so this sum is a kind of a trade-off
like whom has captured the f4 port after
all but played d5 and you can see
immediately that um black will have no
problems with developing his pieces the
bishops are ready to move out and the
Knights will most probably land on their
best squares on f6 and on c6 7 the d5
pawn has gone which will happen most of
the time so 1 this is a very healthy
approach to focus on development and not
try to take the pawn keep it and yeah
what does the weather storms or to say
when white starts its attack um just
briefly looking at this position white
really doesn't have any great
alternatives one simple thing which
nevertheless sometimes happens in bullet
games or something
this white take the table by taking here
when black immediately wins with queen
edge form a form after all weakens the
King so here you just win the rook in
the corner or white would white would
need to to move his King here and and
here also like his winning immediately
changing the King around and winning
material so white cannot take on e5 and
he simply doesn't have much much other
moves here he can well somebody ignore
this situation in the center here but
you can just take on f4 him and there's
nothing else than this move so it's just
a transposition um white could go maybe
Knight c3 these moves are very rare but
a simple answer to this would be just
Knight f6 transposing to the vienna game
which usually arises why a knight c2 on
the second move Knight f6 and then f1 so
just to mention this this moves briefly
but white will in 99% of the time just
take here so you take on f4
and now what almost invariably plays
Knight f3 um you can look briefly here
at Bishop c4 on here um black actually
can take the chance and give this check
on h4 um this placing the King Y place
King at 1 he doesn't have much else and
now you can play Bishop d6 and try to
prepare to ya keep the f4 pawn now and
also having the Queen actively posted on
h5 so you maybe even have some chances
to yet to launch an attack late on the
King you can just develop here
cancelling to come also you could
consider g5 in such a position but of
course this kind of moves are always oh
yeah very um yeah very committal of
course um we are black has no particular
problems here white still plays almost
all the time
Knight to f3 after which like just
develops and yeah I'll show a couple of
possible lines now but what all these
lines have in common is that black
usually makes very sensible developing
moves the focus is get the pieces out
now get the pawn on d5 bank okay but
White has problems keeping it anyway but
just develop the pieces and trying to
get the quick castling in um yeah White
has a couple of moves now and we will go
through them the main move from is maybe
we should be 5 check which yeah solar
forces a concession from black but let's
look briefly at the other moves if white
tries to to keep his pawn here we see
form then oh this is some an important
point to remember black will play c6
here and open the position up
immediately
black is
player here with ya with better
development and also would potentially
better King because black will Castle
quickly and have a safe King while white
simply lacks the F pawn here so on the
possible continuation here would be of
white except this let's say something
along these lines black can give this
check EO developed quickly and now use
the pin we should be too and now this is
nothing you need to to memorize really
but just to show how quickly things can
go wrong for white here like in this
position can castle and sacrifice this
piece because he's got a nasty pin going
on the youth on the e-file don't want to
analyze this deeply here but like got
his piece Beckett has a strong attack he
went down to win quick game against
pretty strong player I don't have the
names here in my father there was white
was the 2300 something play and black
was the Grandmaster so need to focus on
development here and get the King
quickly to castling um just the
development is key here white can also
and this is the most played move here
play on d4 in this position after which
black gives us check again and
recaptures on d5 this is all very very
logical and now let's say Knight here
and now we got a position or maybe maybe
Bishop g4 first maybe this is better I
didn't enter this move in my preparation
here let's say Bishop preform well when
when black has sown yeah very nice
development and white has slab problems
here with the dip on it's an isolated
pawn but the unusual factors that the F
pawn is miss
and maybe the six pawn let's say F 26 of
the bought this would be rather normal
isolated pawn position here black has a
nice development and also can use some
defaults a target and of course like it
some very solid um um this is at best
equal for white I would say um yeah this
is the C formal um what else can why do
we can continue developing night C to a
93 after which you just recapture the
pawn and just simply you get your pieces
out there's not not much more to to know
here let's say Bishop c4 just capture it
should be six castles castles and well
black even has this extra pawn on f4
white didn't manage yet to get it back
end I don't see any particular problems
I think this is just an extra pawn I'm
not sure what white compensation should
be here um a white could take on d5 play
deform and this is somewhat important
point um here the black cam would have
the opportunity to to give a check on
this is my main movie in or we should be
seven to give it give a check here after
which white simply would move his king
this is an important point sometimes you
have those tempting possibilities with
this kind of check here and this is
often not very effective because um
why doesn't mind so much to move the
king to f2 and he has the idea of quick
developing the bishop won't have one and
play rook e1 and you just put your queen
in one one file the e-file with your
king so this is some
yeah recipe for disaster I would say so
not the check here just simply continue
developing let's say B should be 7c for
note that if white takes here you can
get the check as it wins the piece on c4
and just drop the Queen back temporarily
also keeping this pawn it's not such a
big deal the extra pawn so the same but
the nice thing about this pawn is as
long as you keep it for a while it
simply restrict some White's position
the business of c1 bishop cannot go to
an active square it's just hindered by
this pawn and why doesn't have such a
simple way to retake it or at least
needs to make some concessions to get it
back
yeah the following moves would be just
quick development castles Bishop g4 9 to
c6 or d7 and you can just yeah play a
nice a nice game with with a good piece
play on the UH Knight c3 is also pretty
rare move um ship c4
this is some more solid choice um black
recaptures here and now white most often
just castles an alternative here would
be to take on d5 which sometimes is
played and then Knight c3 idea being to
to win a tempo on the Queen um there are
quite a lot of squares the Queen could
move to and I think more than one square
is fine um but I want for Queen to f5
which lends some protection to f4 and
allows some still allows quick
development um let's say T 496 Queen e2
to disturb like a bit and Bishop e7
and like we'll just continue developing
here of course you need to check check
here
stuff like d5 may be disturbing the
night but there's also night before as a
possible threat on c2 this is also
positive point about the Queen on f5 in
term supports these kind of operations
and if black gum is allowed to it would
even play Bishop e6 here and long castle
even um to be honest them if white
doesn't get anything quickly here is
just a pawn down has a lousy position um
um I'm not sure deform and I mean I'm
not sure what what's the best here
really for for white um also he could
could Castle here
1964 Bishop e6 note this is possible
here
d5 like an Castle long but all these
kind of moves are not very complicated I
think to even find over the board so you
just need to get your pieces out quickly
it's not something highly sophisticated
to do um so Bishop takes d5 is so not so
dangerous
um in a recent game I'm played on grand
master level um Hikaru Nakamura played
the white side against Michael Adams and
he canceled there should be six um and
then like and were up late we should be
3c5 and here he um played them somewhat
weird I'm not sure weird button you
played the King edge one in this
position d4 is my main move but King
edge one after which Adams played just
ninety six and maybe you can look this
game up Adams completely outplayed
Nakamura with black and just went astray
in time travel well you know that you
all know that Nakamura is
very dangerous with a long time and
tactics coming but black is just fine in
this position already here but Adams
went on to build up a really nice
advantage um the move which is somewhat
unusual here is c5 in this move you
might want to really remember here
because it helps to control the center
usually black focuses on quick piece
play like knight c6 and so on but this
is some a problem here because with
Bishop b3 wider prepared stuff like this
yeah maybe it's not possible right now
but this is the general idea to get the
pawns rolling and you don't want your
pieces as punishing backs for this pawns
so it's a good idea to put this pawn in
the center um I play might continue
besides the Nakamura's King h1 d4 and
after this black captures and develops
and this is I think maybe what's the
idea about King edge want to get the
King out of this diagonal in a in a game
I found it went this way and black had
no problems at all is slightly better
developed here and has no weaknesses
what's important as a general remark
this kind of structures with three pawns
here on the Kings side two points here
and white three here and two here so
this kind of structures arise very often
in this Sun in this line and what you
need to notice on that quite often um
despite the rather simply simplistic
look of the position on a black in fact
might have some chances to to do
something in the long run and this is
because White's King has some wood
weaker than legs King he just lacks one
pony em Black has three pawns to cover
the King white only two and very often
you can really
get some kind of tech going here let's
just for instance say a black would get
a bishop on the long diagonal here see
62 he would always have pressure on g2
if white would try this let's say he
plays the big poem Bishop b2 black would
always have the option to play f6
blunting this bishop so why it has less
defensive resources here this position
here is objectively and maybe equal but
it it gives chances to to play for
something in the long run this kind of
structure also arises frequently out of
the Sicilian defense and very often
black young scores quite nicely there um
let's go back here quickly the Queen e2
is also an option besides B should be
three but there's nothing special to
remember here you just develop it should
be seven and castles um let's say 93 c6
deform and now I'm you actually have a
choice the the main move in this
position is g5 keeping this pawn but you
can also simply continue developing
there's nothing wrong with this just
don't get your pieces out and white
still would need some time to to
recapture the pawn so I don't see much
danger here to be honest
um let's return to this position um we
should be five checkers as mentioned the
main move and he have like pretty um
according to the the general concept
here places six to speed up development
so not some clumsy looking move like
let's say Bishop d7 after white I think
would most like to retreat and then you
you don't get get this back so easily
plus the bishop is just ugly on d7 you
don't really want to get it to g4 early
so development is key
here just place your six white captures
Knight X and now black already has got
two nights on the best-possible squares
materially it's equal yeah because we
just grabbed this F for pawn so we could
easily return one on c6 and now on white
usually goes for default it needs to at
least try to get this pawn back Bishop
d6 and white now usually goes for this
Queen e2 move we need to do something
concrete here if he just let's say play
some quiet moves like just continues
developing it has a fine position it's
also not easy to to see how white would
get there for pawn as as I mentioned the
issue is not so much um that this yeah
in fact here it was the extra pawn black
already has sacrificed one point back
and but it's just hinders White's pieces
this Bishop in particular and it weakens
the weaknesses here are much more
prominent with a pawn in existence let's
say Knight d5 a3 might be an option or
rook to e3 this is just in a weak square
on on only three here supported by the
pawn and black has some I think just a
very nice play here we need to check
Bishop Bishop to e6 95 and castles very
logical just let white take here because
some black is far better developed it
still may be the best move
something like this and now castles
white can also capture here King edge
eight and now we can take stock quickly
here black ass and sacrifice one pawn
but of course it's got very nice a very
nice position which can be an observed
by some nice tactics here if white
castles black has a surprising move
Bishop c5 you don't need to memorize
this will move thirteen but just to see
the kind of stuff that can arise you
have white goes to the spawn webbing
route white captures like as a check and
white doesn't have much else line King
edge one and then Knight to e4 black has
sacrificed a piece here but it's very
difficult for Y to even retain a
playable position he is already forced
to return heavy material he I don't want
to analyze it in detail if you have some
time and then just put this position
into some some computer engine and try
to defend this was wide it's very tough
of course the key point is that um that
black is threatening this move here
let's say c3 Knight EF white captures
it's checkmate on the back rank and this
of course allows the classic smothered
made on f2 so this development
disadvantage gap can get ugly quickly so
white usually also just castle CM and
here you can just continue playing this
position I would sorry I would suggest
to maybe go for a move like Queen c7
here or 95 keeping there for porn for
some time and and I think black is just
fine here we've got equal material and
black and play
- yeah ae8 next maybe you go E 5 or C 5
it's um it's just a good position um
yeah that's it the Kings gambit in 25
minutes and I'm not quite sure why
people are so afraid or odd I don't know
if rate is maybe it's too strong a word
but worried that it says so much to
learn
I think this is really everything you
you basically need to know get to this
position and then here just focus on
good development it's always useful of
course to to study as some games in this
line you'll find plenty of firm strong
players going for this as black because
it's simply a very economical choice you
don't need to study um lots of
complicated four slides here and this is
just a sensible way to approach the
King's gambit because you get it so
rarely and serious some serious
tournament chess that it doesn't make
much sense to to learn those terribly
complicated lines involved in taking ng5
they're very interesting of course but
it's not really yeah practical um one
thing I'd like to show is
to offbeat tries just quickly this I
want to show in detail but I just want
to mention them as a kind of cool side
line that that side lines that are
possible one line that I regularly play
in in blitz chess or or bullet shares
very very quick tab controls here's
ninety-six and this is quite a tricky
move Knight f3
note that still this is not possible of
course of because it's a check right f3
and then the crazy looking with f5 this
is the kind of line um which I show but
I don't really recommend to you to be
use it all the time I just wanted to
show that this is quite a fun
alternative if you look for something
fun to play in in those speedy games
then this can net a lot of lots of quick
points the point is that lots of moves
now need to complete disaster for white
but they are nevertheless played quite
often in in slow in quick time control
games for instance Knight takes e5
losses immediately because of the
standard procedure here um white also
sometimes goes from oops
for this capture and oops black takes
here then you see that the knight really
has no moves white yeah has 2 SEC this
Knight or return all the way after this
black just captures and it quite funny
you have extra Tempe and the next report
so black is just just winning after 5
moves so white cannot take on on e5 in
any of them in any sort of fashion um
you can take on f5 then you have the
movie 495 and then black has a choice
even between taking
five or nine f6 I usually play Knight f6
and then continue with stuff like d6 y
taking here and then I take on f5 um
let's say moves like this here and then
black will take on f5 next which leads
to here Messier but interesting position
um a white can try an gambit style here
stuff like this queen h5 pretty
complicated stuff but it's it's fun to
play in this quick time control games
and so if you look some for some crazy
looking stuff but fun stuff f5 really
fits the bill it's it's not it's not
refuted or something and if you check
the databases or do some computer
analysis it's it seems playable it looks
weird but seems playable um in fact
maybe the best move from whites side
here this is d3 and this was yeah not to
move most people would come up with
after this black can just play d6 and
game goes on from him certainly this is
nothing to write home about
for white so this kind of crazy line is
playable but if you look at this
position just just form
yeah comparisons sake if you imagine
White's pawn on f2 and what's bishop
won't be five you would have the
Schliemann gambit of the of the Spanish
opening through of the reuleaux pass and
here instead of the the reuleaux pass
move from Bishop b5 White has played a
form so if the Schliemann this is a good
line and most probably it is why
shouldn't this be playable because f4 is
arguably a less useful move than B
should be 5 yeah this is my offbeat
recommendation against the Kings game
but if you want to have some some crazy
complications but it's something you
should of course study a bit
before you would consider playing this
in a really important serious tournament
game let's say but if you are you're
playing some blitz games why not have
some fun with their five five I have I
think close to ninety percent or
something with black in in blitz and
bullets game through this because people
are simply not not prepared to face this
most likely they never saw it so it's
it's quite a quite a funny alternative
but it's one of those don't try this at
home lines or at least don't try this at
home before you have studied it really
so my main my main will can be
recommendation is d5 let's as shown and
this is my my offbeat line for for some
crazy fun if you don't care so much
about the result maybe well if you just
want to have a crazy position yeah
thanks for watching and um I'll do new
video most likely tomorrow I'm not quite
sure if I'll make it on on Monday um and
this will be about more sidelines on
move to let's say the Vienna the
Bishop's opening I get from the
sidelines to the main line some
step-by-step yeah thanks for watching
see you soon